we have a voicemail number that number
is
219 to david p here is just
a nice friendly voicemail these are
relatively rare
this is high praise for the show and our
our staff take a look hey dave
john just wanted to thank you um i think
everyone would agree that you've
assembled a wonderful team around you
well not not everyone would agree not
everyone would agree but i'm glad that
at least
some people do you should see my voice
my inbox though not everybody agrees
you have a sense of a greater good and a
logical discourse that allows
others to understand your point of view
even if they don't agree
bravo i love the praise unfortunately
john is giving a lot of the people in
our in our audience too much credit and
i'm i'm talking about the haters
who don't understand what i'm talking
about and they will write to me
defiantly and strongly telling me i was
wrong
about something i didn't even say that
may be actually one of the more you know
people say
the what about the insults through the
insults the insults you get used to
what's
very frustrating is getting emails from
people
furious with me about something i didn't
say
angry with me about an argument i didn't
make um
because it just yeah it's like punching
a paper bag or whatever to
try to pun trying to punch your way out
of a wet paper bag or maybe there's some
other
analogy or metaphor that makes more
sense listen i have something very nice
to announce today
um we've had so much just
deep election related stuff going on
that tomorrow thursday night december
3rd
at 8 pm eastern i will be co-hosting a
chess
tournament with the international
master levy rosman okay
levy and i are co-hosting this
tournament it starts at 8 p.m eastern
and you can join the david pakman
chess club at chess.com to participate
uh at davidpakman.com chess
davidpakman.comchessdavidpakman.com
chess that'll redirect you and you can
join my chess.com chess club this is all
free i'm not
selling you anything other than a good
time um tomorrow
starting at 7 eastern you will be able
to register for the tournament which
will start at 8. i will be playing in
the tournament and streaming
levy rosman will be playing in the
tournament and streaming for the first
hour
it'll be a 90-minute tournament the last
half hour levy and i will be doing
commentary on the games
of some of the folks who will be leading
uh who are
who are in the lead at that point in
time no chess experience necessary
play a little today get familiar with
the game davidpakman.com i think it will
be a great time it'll be a great break
from politics uh grand master benjamin
feingold who's a supporter of the david
pakman show
has agreed to play in the tournament and
there may be some other chess
stars who will be playing so this is if
you if you just want politics this isn't
for you
but if you want to participate in the
community and you like the idea of doing
something a little bit different
i hope you will join us davidpakman.com
chess join the chess club and then
tomorrow
night you'll be able to register for the
tournament all right on the bonus show
today
we now with the approval of the pfizer
coronavirus vaccine in the uk
and that same approval expected here in
the next seven to ten days
we are starting to see priority lists
about
who should get the vaccine first in what
order
do health care workers go before nursing
home residents
or not these are the types of questions
that are now being discussed
and which we will discuss on today's
bonus show also
brazilian amazon deforestation has
surged
and lastly activists have dropped body
bags
outside the homes of a number of
prominent republicans
um related to the pandemic related to a
desired second coronavirus stimulus all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com